[Musique]
bonjour giuseppe bettoni merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin sur
rtl france une allocation universelle
pour tous les italiens donc à partir du
mois de juillet c'est une première est
ce que c'est une bonne nouvelle
c'est une première et surtout c'est une
dimension très importante parce que
jusque là il faut pas oublier que il y
avait que les employés qui recevait une
sorte de haie de par chaque fils pour
une progression il était une quantité
vraiment risible pour faire un exemple
en a un père avec deux enfants pouvaient
recevoir 90 euros par mois comme
allocation
donc c'est assez ridicule pour ne pas
parler que tous les professionnels
n'étaient pas inclus dans ce type de
aides
aujourd'hui l'italie est à 1% du pib
comme allocation de ce type
enfin en europe la moyenne est de 2
points 2 donc ça veut dire qu'on est
vraiment très très loin si cette
allocation se met en place
l'italie pratiquement va rajouter 6
milliards aux 15 milliards de héros que
normalement elle investit dans ce type
de haine mais surtout ça va être très
homogène plus répondu à 250 euros par
enfant alors que vous disiez avance mais
s'était réservé simplement à une partie
de des employés sous forme de crédits
d'impôts une allocation universelle pour
relancer la natalité pourquoi l'italie a
besoin de deux bébés à l'italien grand
besoin de bb1 grande maison de natalité
vitaly ça fait des décennies qui est le
dernier du peloton alors le dernier
depuis des décennies mais là le problème
devient tragédie parce que d'emblée que
cette année pour la cause du coc vide
nous que nous avons 60 millions 400
mille habitants l'année dernière on
risque de redescendre en dessous
de la barre des 60 millions entre les
naissances et les décès des nous avons
perdu presque 400 mille habitants donc
vous comprenez bien que c'est une
tragédie dans la maison de laquelle il
ya des parties de l'italie du territoire
italien qui sont complètement à
l'abandon presque vides alors que des
partis notamment sur la côte sont dans
une pression démographique énorme
nommément le cadenas
donc c'est un gros gros problème qui ne
concerne pas mal de questions
fondamentalement le système des
retraites mais n'a pas que ça il a
vraiment la relance économique doit
s'appuyer sur des jeunes sous des
naissances et nous l'avons pas l'italie
n'a jamais parlé mais vraiment aider les
familles sinon par une pression sociale
à faire des enfants mais qui n'a jamais
été suivie par une action de soutien par
rapport à l'économie etc
et est ce que va engendrer évidemment
cette allocation universelle c'est un
soutien au pouvoir d'achat dans cette
grave crise économique
alors c'est très important parce
qu'effectivement on va arriver à voir
oui vous avez raison c'est 250 euros
maximum par famille
mais à réalité en moyenne sans vous
faire des calculs exacts les parties les
plus basses de la de la pyramide
économique il ya deux tranches grosso
modo enfin une troisième maximale mais
ça reste assez large pour y avoir un
moyenne 161 euros par enfant mineur
par famille et si vous avez un enfant
majeur à de 18 et 21 vous pouvez arriver
à 9 ans à 98 euros par mois ça peut
faire donc quand même la différence si
vous avez trois enfants ou deux enfants
un mineur l'autre majeur c'est ça veut
dire déjà une augmentation de 250 euros
est rappelons le les salaires en italie
peuvent aller de 800 à 1300 euros donc
il s'agit quand même d'une part
importante du salaire qui pourrait
ergoter qui va changer effectivement la
donne alors que je
mais ce qu'on appelle à saigne et
familiale chef à milo qui concerne que
les employés aujourd'hui sont presque
invisibles dans la fiche de paye des
employés ce qui est montré également
dans ce levier scellé la situation des
femmes est ce que ça va améliorer aussi
la situation des femmes qui travaillent
en italie et qui ont été durement
impactés par cette crise on se rappelle
moi je le souhaite mais je ne pense pas
que ça que cette action-là pourrait
vraiment changé la donne lya un
changement dans une population qui n'est
pas comment dire machiste d'une manière
très évidente ou pas plus qu'ailleurs
mais qui réserve encore aux femmes une
partie pas du tout importante surtout
quand on pense par exemple à la
leadership d'un certain parti politique
quand on pense à la direction générale
le comité de surveillance à niveau de
santé national mis en place par le
gouvernement déjà compté du comité était
composé que par des hommes alors on se
disait mais comment ça se fait et
l'excusé était mais nous on a fait par
les responsables de la santé publique
italienne dans ce comité au comité mais
on se trouve que les responsables de ce
comité et dès que des hommes
donc le problème est vraiment culturel
de pouvoir finalement laissé la place
dans tous les camps aussi décisionnel
autant que de soutien économique les
femmes sont encore énormément
discriminés en italie par rapport à leur
emploi au fait des grossesses par
rapport à leurs possibilités d'embauché
donc j'espère que cela va aider des
familles et donc les femmes être comme
on dirait plus liban de certains points
de vue mais je pense qu'il a encore un
très grand chemin à faire et on a vu que
ce problème de natalité était expliquée
par cette crise sanitaire qui dure
depuis un an maintenant c'est un peu le
cas partout en europe
l'italie également ce problème a été
exacerbé par la crise sanitaire
énormément parce qu'effectivement il y à
un manque d'eau
science seul à venir surtout vu la la
pauvre visibilité que nous avons sur
l'avenir pas tellement sur la réaction
économique sur laquelle nous tous nous
voulons espérer encore qu'il faudrait
faire une parenthèse par rapport à la
grosse dette publique on va se retrouver
par la suite mais en même temps on n'a
pas de visibilité par rapport à ce que
vraiment va pouvoir devenir contre cela
va s'arrêter
de quelle manière même dépassé cela va
affecter nos attitudes beaucoup de
couples aujourd'hui ne font pas
d'efforts et n'oublions pas qu'à
l'italie si les familles ne font pas de
couple c'est aussi parce que les couples
se marient très tardivement à l'italie
les enfants restent très longtemps à la
maison avec leurs parents les femmes
attendent de pouvoir vraiment avoir une
grosse possibilité professionnel pour
pouvoir faire des enfants
on dépasse largement les 30 ans souvent
un couple décide de faire des enfants
qu'on y arrive à dépasser les 35 ans
vous avez bien qu'à la cour de fertilité
attendre cinq ans elle devient très peu
de choses question complètement si vous
y dire si vous le voulez bien on a vu en
les restaurateurs et les lire et les
commerçants manifester vous pensez que
l'embellie va et c'est pourquoi en
italie quand on voit les images de
grande bretagne
ça fait envie ça fait très envie mais
c'est pas pour demain
notre gouvernement est très stricte à la
fois le gouvernement précédent à la fois
suivi là et la population tient le coup
l'italien données pro d'une grande
endurance par rapport à cette question
nous un grand respect des règles il y à
une communauté celle des restaurateurs
qui protestent ils ont les autres c'est
compréhensible
nous en connaissons tous quelques-uns et
nous savons à quel point souffre nous
savons si que beaucoup de ces fini ils
sont morts le restaurant est finie et
mais en même temps tout le monde
investie sur le fait de redresser la
courbe la courbe semble s'améliorer
quoi qu'on a encore beaucoup de morts
c'est pas la protestation qu'on a vu sur
vos écrans qui est la preuve d'un mal
être terrible dans la population
mais c'est pas pour ça qu'on m'a
vraiment ouvrir les sans aucune
visibilité je vous rappelle qu encore
aujourd'hui en italie il est interdit de
se déplacer d'une région à l'autre
depuis des mois désormais et jusqu'au 30
avril et ça va être comme ça il est fort
probable que une certaine liberté va
être possible dès le mois de mai juin
mais je ne pense pas qu'ils viendraient
reprise d'activité économique avant le
mois de septembre
merci beaucoup de josé pb tony d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur rt france